des pertes effarante parmi la population
civile en irak attribuable groupes armés
états islamiques mais aussi aux forces
pro gouvernementales selon un nouveau
rapport près de 19 mille personnes ont
été tuées en moins de deux ans en raison
du conflit et plus de trente six mille
autres ont été blessés
les djihadistes aurait notamment réduit
à l'esclavagé environ 3500 personnes des
femmes surtout et des enfants issus de
la minorité religieuse yazidi conflit a
aussi fait des millions de déplacés à
l'intérieur du pays
le rapport prévient que certains actes
commis par le groupe etat islamique sont
des crimes de guerre des crimes contre
l'humanité ou un génocide et que le
bilan réel est probablement encore
beaucoup plus lourd